- [Voiceover] So we've got
an infinite series here.
Negative one to the n plus
one over the square root of n.
I always like to visualize this
a little bit more, expand it out.
So when n equals one the
first term is negative one
to the second power, so
it's going to be positive.
It's going to be one
over one and so it's one
minus one over the square root of two
plus one over the square root of three
minus one over the square
root of four and then
plus, minus, and we just go
on and on and on forever.
Now when we looked at convergence tests
for infinite series we
saw things like this.
This passes the alternating series test
and so we know that this converges.
Let's say it converges to some value S.
But what we're concerned
with in this video is
not whether or not this
converges, but estimating
what this actually converges to.
We know that we can estimate
this by taking a partial sum.
Let's say S sub k, this is the
first k terms right over here
and then you're going to have a remainder,
so plus the remainder after
you've taken the first k terms.
So this actually starts
with the k plus first term.
And so what I am concerned
about or what I want
to figure out is what's the
minimum number of terms,
what's the minimum k here
so that my remainder,
so that the absolute value of my remainder
is less than or equal to 0.001.
And I encourage you to
pause the video based
on what we've seen in previous
alternating series estimation situations
to see if you can figure this out.
Alright I'm assuming
you've had a go at it.
So let's just remind ourselves
what R sub k looks like.
So R sub k is going to start
with the k plus first term.
So it's going to be negative
one k plus one plus one,
so it's negative one
to the k plus two over
the square root of k plus one.
And then the next term
I can just write plus
negative one to the k plus three over
the square root of k plus two.
And it's just going to go
on and on and on like that.
Now what we know already or
what we've seen an example of
and we'll verify it or at
least conceptual verification
for us at the end of this
video is the absolute
value of this entire sum
is going to be less than
the absolute value of the first term.
So let me write that down.
The absolute value of this
entire remainder R sub k...
And some people refer
to this as kind of the
alternating series remainder property
or whatever you want to call it.
But the absolute value
of this entire thing
is going to be less than or
equal to the absolute value
of the first term, negative
one to the k plus two
over the square root of k plus one.
And of course we want that to
be less than one thousandth.
So that needs to be less
than or equal to 0.001.
And so now this setup
right over here inspires
you, I once again encourage
you to pause the video
and see if you can figure out what is
the minimum k that
satisfies this inequality.
Well once again I'm assuming
you've had a go at it.
And the key realization here is that this
negative one to the k plus
two this makes this whole
thing either positive or negative.
The denominator is going to be positive.
Well it's definitely going
to be positive for all
the ks frankly for
which the principal root
is going to be defined, but obviously
these are all positive ks as well.
So the numerator here just flips the sign.
We flip between negative
one or positive one,
negative one or positive one.
But if we take the
absolute value whether it's
negative or positive it's
going to end up being positive.
So this thing on the left
hand side that's the same
thing as just one over the
square root of k plus one
and then that's going to be
less than or equal to 0.001.
And now we just have to
solve this inequality.
Find out which ks satisfy this inequality.
And so let's see, we
can multiply both sides
by the square root of k plus one.
So square root of k plus one so we can
get this out of the denominator.
And let's actually multiple
both sides times 1,000
because this is a thousandth
and so we'll end up
with a one on the right-hand side.
So times 1,000, times 1,000.
And what we're going to be left with is
these cancel out on the left-hand side.
We don't have to flip the sign because
we just multiplied by positive things.
So we have 1,000 is less than or equal to
the square root of k plus one.
We could square both
sides and we get 1,000,000
is less than or equal to k plus one.
And then we can just
subtract one from both sides
and we have 999,999 is going
to be less than or equal to k.
So k just has to be greater
than or equal to 999,999.
And remember we want the smallest k
that satisfies these conditions.
So the smallest k if k has to be
greater than or equal to this,
the smallest k that satisfies
this is k is equal to 999,999.
So let's write that down.
So the smallest k for which this is true
is going to be k is equal to 999,999.
Now let's convince ourselves
that that remainder,
that the absolute value
of the remainder is
definitely going to be less...
If we take the partial sum of the first
999,999 terms that this remainder is
actually going to be less than this.
I'm telling you so far
we've just kind of worked
from the premise that it will be,
but let's actually look at
that and feel good about it.
And once again encourage you to
pause the video and try it on your own.
So let's just rewrite this again,
but I'm going to expand out R sub k.
So we're saying that it's
all going to converge to S
and we're going to take the
partial sum of the first
999,999 terms and we're
claiming that this is going
to be within one thousandth
of this right over here.
So this is going to be plus and
so the first term of the remainder,
of R sub k is going to
be our millionth term.
And so the millionth term, we
just have to remind ourselves,
is going to be negative one
to the million and oneth power
so negative one to the
million and oneth power
that's going to be negative one
because that's an odd number.
So it's going to be negative one over
the square root of a million.
So actually let me do it like this.
So it's going to be minus one
over the square root of a million.
And then the next term is going to be plus
one over the square root
of a million and one.
And it's positive now
because this is gonna be
negative one to the
million and second power.
And then it's going to be minus one over
the square root of one million and two.
And then plus, I'll
just do two more terms.
One over the square root
of a million and three.
And then minus one over the square root of
a million and four and then plus, minus,
it just keeps going on and
on, on and on and on forever.
Now I want to convince
ourselves that this thing
is going to be, the
absolute value of this thing
is going to be less than one thousandth.
It's going to be essentially less than the
absolute value of this first term.
So how do we think about it?
So this first term we already know,
this right over here is this
first term right over here is
negative 0.001 because
it's one over one thousand
and we have this negative right over here.
Now the first thing we could realize,
if we just put parentheses like this,
we see that this is going to be positive,
this term is larger than this term,
and we could keep going.
So the remainder kind of starts
at negative one thousandth
and then it just adds a
bunch of positive terms.
So it's not going to get
any more negative than this.
So we know that the remainder
can't get more negative
than this, but let's
also verify that it can't
get more than a positive
thousandth either.
And the way that we can
do that is to just look
at the parentheses in a different way.
If we do it this way that's
going to be a negative value.
This right over here is
And we can say plus that, plus that,
and so we're going to have a
bunch of negative values together.
So just like that by really looking at the
parentheses a little bit
differently we're able
to say that this is definitely
going to be negative.
This remainder is definitely
going to be a negative value,
but it can't be any more
negative than our first term.
So that tells us that the
absolute value of our remainder
can't get any larger than one thousandth.
As we add more and more
and more terms here
we're not going to get
any further away from
the actual sum than the first term.